[Music]
[Music]
and it has begun the final night Sims
and left go live in Atlanta at Dan
Tana's we're listening to rots and this
music and right here we got a bunch of
kings in the audience but we have King
Mel
Melvin Ingram on the set who Sims said
after the game against Baltimore had the
greatest game of any defensive player
the entire season round of applause for
the man Melton yeah no problem and put
it on my tab put on my tab man I got you
my girl yeah I mean start right there I
mean yeah because that was one of those
games for like the loyal listeners when
you talk about like the statute the
statute was awesome but when you watch
the rest of the game and how many other
plays you ruined what was it about the
second time around kind of facing that
offense that let you just tee off like
that I just had you just have more time
to prepare for them really you just
played them ten days before that so you
kind of pretty much know everything they
go come out with and if they don't
change then you really know everything
they go yeah so it was just more of just
studying everything they had going on
and like in the season and when the more
wanted to keep the ball when he wanted
to give it off so so it was just things
like that yeah I mean just so we know
the stat line six tackles 2 sacks but a
whole bunch of [ __ ] the play up stat
know what I'm talking about
yes whole bunch of them that's awesome
so the first thing that he says when he
walks in is you know you guys cheated
right they did Sims and left go the show
we competed and you're still you're
still upset at us I am I am yeah we know
we see just so you know when we did this
show and if you haven't sitting you got
to go back and watch it we did Jenga but
like he intimidated all the producers on
our show he would they would break rules
and they were so scared to tell him no
you can't do that we had one woman go
now that's against the rules and he said
no it's not no it's not it was and she
just went okay that's good points good
points good they just just like that
just like
we had it we had a great rift she was
amazing she was really cheap for y'all
all the call it Nicole she was a great
room yeah y'all really cheated on it's
our show it's like coming to England you
better you better have all your gear
ready you know what I mean all right we
didn't mean that pearl I just having fun
I like the pictures I just having fun so
I've noticed so I've noticed whenever
you win a big game you'd hold the camera
up and you went on this magical phrase
that you had and I thought it was can
you do it for everybody
hey Sam any squad any place we bought
whatever we pulled it up with pressure
and and so I watched I was like who came
up with this and you came up with it
yeah yeah it was just a game it was a
whole lot of gang [ __ ] with us you guys
are I mean between you both Derwin you
got a lighter one here the other day a
whole bunch of scary dudes on your
defense show for sure okay so just like
first thing is you're in LA who you
rooting for in this Super Bowl do you
root for the Rams of the Patriot Oh like
me the one I know you're a tough spot
right it's messed up I was thinking
about you before I came here somebody
he's not gonna like either one of these
teams all right so wait you got to feel
like a little disrespected by maybe the
lack of attention you guys get in LA
already does that kind of piss you off
no not really man we dare to play
football yeah that's what it's all about
no matter what if you get a lot of
attention if you don't get no attention
in the game still gonna go on on Sunday
right so man we just gotta play football
all right and then we already wax
poetically about the greatest game you
played by any defensive player all year
for man the following week I've seen
better
and not just from you I'm just saying
the whole team like you didn't have a
chance no doubt about it the game plan
by them was amazing but I just want you
to talk about it like what's it like
playing the Patriots machine when you
when it's rolling like that oh it was a
tough game and they I felt like they
came out of insecurity everything they
they had in the game plan you can't take
nothing away from them right they came
out a deal what they were supposed to do
right that's I mean what do you what are
you like what are the Rams supposed to
do if he
getting it out that quickly just gotta
get them and then that's what it is you
got it you got our you got to stay calm
you can't let that affect you right cuz
cuz the pages of the type of team
they're gonna take what you give ya
ain't gonna try to meet no big plays
they take their six whole days and they
go take them in one thing by the rim if
they got a high-power offense - so is
they both gonna be scoring right the
Rams got full first rounders on the
front line I know so I know everything
over like Donnell autumn boy they're
gonna go crazy to be ready Aaron Donald
impress you - yeah can you kiss for us
we look at him and we see what the
muscles are but just when you if you see
him on film what what does he show you
yeah great player man he was he one of
the best players ever played his game
really I think he's still growing really
as a player after he reached his peak
yet and that's scary
yeah he's definitely one of the best
ever pseudo man when you played the
Patriots did you think they were gonna
come out and run the ball like so
heavily that did anything catch you by
surprise about no I felt like the I knew
they was gonna have a balanced office ya
know what they came out and did they ran
the ball threw the ball right they got
some big tackles dude that's where I've
always like how big is Trent Brown he be
like he's like what six seven eight
something like that maybe six nine yeah
he's up there I mean I know he's like
he's definitely like three of you and me
maybe just like one and a half ahead
were they better than then they looked
on tape their offensive line not a what
they was dude they came out and they was
exactly what you expected they just they
what they do they do it well Brady make
Brady make a lot of that [ __ ] look
better than what it is yeah yeah what
about okay I want to talk about like
some other guys you played this year I
mean you you got to play Patrick mahomes
twice what what what jumped out to you
about playing him just everything his
arm strength yeah your magician baton in
their pocket for real man and and some
of the throws he make is just it's like
video games I could see you like lighten
up but you're actually talking about
like I give credit where credit door so
I'm gonna [ __ ] he Dubrow is like no-look
passes and all that is just like a guy
hanging on this Jersey and don't want to
touch down in the Thursday night game
zactly it's crazy
right you just got to give credit where
credit do it yeah yeah what was it like
to go in the Kansas City and get the
Dove oh man it was big you know we
hadn't beaten him in a while yeah so it
was just we had to keep their feet no
matter what we had to keep their feet so
your buddy is now now you play bachelor
for homes twice a year for the rest of
like you know a long time sorrowful sure
how does that rivalry continued to
blossom because I have a feeling that
Chargers Chiefs fighting for the top of
the AFC West is like the next five years
yeah but here we got to make it happen
yeah we gotta we gotta hold the top see
man and when you do that it's a big
advantage for you yeah this year you
guys didn't get us so you got the five
yeah and that's crazy
great let's talk about that second best
record in the AFC and you're the five
seed they don't it don't make no sense
to me I don't I don't understand how
that works I never understood how yeah
you get rewarded from one of the
division and then I know it's tough
because you definitely shouldn't have
been the father I know that's it is what
you know and you talk about like having
a bye week all right so you're I mean I
know you guys are a SAP like you're
saying but at the same time how about
your stadium what do you guys get a
little like pissed off about maybe not
having a home-field advantage yet I mean
it is kind of amazing I feel like you
play 16 road games that's why we a so
yeah right it don't matter so we'll
pitch it you don't pay attention to it
yeah that's just our identity I know I
just feel like you would take over more
if you just had crowd noise to help you
like it must be that much better so just
a big part it does play a big part when
you go to places that they've really got
that crowd noise right yeah yeah what do
you uh what are you driving these days
man
it's nothing he's gets all boozed up on
this it's all guy he has no more money
always a car guy yeah so what like what
about the roles cuz you know looking for
a car so maybe your oh yeah it's your
rose yeah alright so bleacher report
yeah you gotta up the ante a little
Melvin Ingram's yeah a little bit man
get you a rose I could see you on a
white rose Oh somebody Photoshop me no
white Rolls
right now so uh so when you have a
season like you did Joey is finally back
and healthy Derwin now in the back end
all the pieces you guys had some corners
come out and like Michael Davis right
yeah like very like what what is what
how much more excited are you tick to
just grind this offseason for next year
when the defensive unit is that good
this year very I'm am very excited cuz I
feel like we got a lot of young
seriously good and we studied growing as
a defense we so young which means we
studied growing as a defense in the
sky's the limit man it's gonna be scared
when all the pieces put together and
everybody is really like sit on home and
in a comfort zone and bottom is gonna
get scared oh my god there's this Philip
Rivers like I mean I we love Philips
attitude like it's in fact like is he
like that I'd like to see talk [ __ ] to
you in practice sometimes he will each
other all the time
go ahead like give me some like what
like how he is it's just we just come in
like like we could just be stretching
them we just like he'd like to date man
I'm I'm lights all of the day and I'd
love that
yeah for sure Wikipedia man alright last
thing I got asked all right I gotta ask
I'm gonna ask them the first time but
it's my patent question I got asked you
okay
who's the like who's the tackle and
football that you see I know you're not
scared anybody and you could ball
against anybody who's the one guy that
right when I asked this question just
pops in your mind where you go man he's
a pain in the ass to play against that
guy I got your [ __ ] weather you can't
think anybody there's nobody nobody that
jumps out to you where you just go yeah
your teeth that's what he did some our
people a bleacher poem we got there say
he just says a straight up I can't yeah
yeah amazing year thank you for coming
by appreciate y'all man
yeah man
your event you're a very busy man I know
you got some things to do here so I'm
gonna help you get off the set
we appreciate you my man and I'll hit
you up about the white rolls for
recommendation he's got it he's gotta
say something to the camera I believe
doesn't he
no no no okay you're good we're good
okay sorry sorry that was me I was wrong
I was wrong
he just wants you to say all dope Sims
and Lefko is so if you want to say that
it's definitely dope yeah hit him on the
chest on the way out sorry we're gonna
need a new desk because I thought he
just broke it some little Melvin you're
the man I want to thank everybody here
you guys are awesome to the people that
have been here all week thank you guys
like you guys have made this a great
experience for us I think which it's
been cool to be here at Dan Tana's come
on I'll be on easy and give you behind
the curtain I'm so happy I'm not at
radio row I'm so happy that we get to be
with people that we love and not a bunch
of random strangers and just going hey
hey hey hey hey and you get to see us
interact with the athletes because if
we've met them before we're good with
them we're not we're not we don't do the
hot takes oh we're not at all so what a
little prospects for lecture I did kind
of you kind of did I was exodus coming
out of my mouth I was like yeah you did
kind of go johny broadcaster out of
there interrupting him there notice that
thank you
stop touching me yeah that's the number
one question they've all asked me ask do
you get upset when Sims yells at you for
interrupting gosh well I'm what have a
do I get upset when he interrupts me I
mean I don't know what your thing is you
need to be interrupted sometime no he is
uh he hears me talk so much yes that
that's really the problem I don't I
don't care so I've only yelled at him
like once or twice right there was one
time in like nine hundred episodes I've
yelled it at twice okay yeah yeah yeah
member when you yelled you have a
problem yeah you have a frickin problem
I mean you guys are all so loyal I got
to point out my man again over here the
guy hasn't gotten to school all week
okay that's what that's what's
impressive about our fan
and that's what we like Mack Brown knows
used to go like this he'd always go
school first football second yes and no
that's you right there man and if you're
here and you saw our show last night
where we had teo and chad where we had
who was our guest right in the beginning
Derwin jr. with James right that is
gonna be published on YouTube at 5:00 so
that whole thing will be up there from
my 50-yard throw attempt which I got 49
oh just the bid sure we're gonna be
great that makes me feel so good oh nine
yards the Jenga game with George kiddo
you're kind of like Blake bortles stop
George kid on Trent Taylor the Jenga
game went 52 minutes we added it up the
world record for the longest Jenga game
is an hour and 15 so we were coming
close to the longest Jenga game in the
history of the world I'm so happy we did
it that's how we know you're that
dedicated because you stayed there for
Jenga and he questioned your raccoon yes
I mean what the hell was that right but
you can't say anything jack also took
$20 from you which is hilarious he'll be
back here in a little bit so let me give
you a rundown of today we're gonna place
our final bets of the year on the Super
Bowl I will give you an update of where
our money is and how we're standing of a
few more inner you're not ready for me
if you're messing with me I'm gonna be
soft
you're not ready for me man Julius
Peppers yeah retires after 17 sees right
you played him multiple times a year
when you were at the buck yeah what was
it like face of Julius Peppers Julius
Peppers is in that class of coleus
Campbell whoever it may be like the
first thing you have to recognize is
Julius can't I mean Julius Peppers the
size of the human being like he is one
of those guys and he will attest to this
I played him in college when he was at
North Carolina and I was at Texas and I
ran out and I promise you I got to like
midfield because we're gonna throw Pat
and go and he was right by there and I
went holy [ __ ] and I'm saying this damn
I go I did
realize you're this damn big and he
looked at me like hahaha are you crazy
man you're crazy and I mean so that's
where it starts he is truly a specimen
of a person but playing against him I
saw some of the freakiest things I ever
saw with anybody I saw one-handed
interceptions my rookie year off of Brad
Johnson and he took it to the house
okay I'm spider 2 y banana it was
literally that play spider 2 y banana
that you always hear John Gurdon talk
about the full the full back so full
back went and he was dropping out like
his own blitz and he stuck his hand out
and it's stuck on there like glue and he
went to the house but he was one of
those guys let's go and I know you've
heard me say this a million times one of
the few guys I played where when I would
say set hut underneath the center and as
I would get the ball I would always peek
just a little bit just to see what kind
of jumpy got cuz if I felt like oh damn
he timed that really well maybe around
step four or five in my drop back I was
gonna take one more look to go let me
see where that big mf'er is just so he
doesn't crush me and that's how good he
was and not just pass rush he played the
run - he wasn't just into sack numbers
he did it all he is he will retire the
fourth most sacks in NFL history 159 and
a half hall-of-famer man that into
perspective we are having JJ Watt later
in the show for those that you already
seen it was great he only has 97 right
so Julius Peppers has 159 and a half
which is incredible incredible he's the
only player in NFL history with a
hundred and fifty sacks and ten
interceptions man to go - what you just
said about having a hands right like we
talked about guys go up and swatting it
JJ with that basketball skill set was
going up and go at Ali you yeah I'm
taking that bad yes are we in a right
tackle in Tampa Kenyatta Walker yeah who
had a pressing ttan well he was he went
to Florida Lafayette but he literally
had a jumping offsides problem when he
played kid when he played Julius Peppers
like when we were playing Julius Peppers
that week he was nervous as hell and we
had a stint in 2005 in a home game where
he jumped offsides three plays in a row
because he was so worried about him and
what was this that we heard backstage
somebody said something I think Julia's
pepper is the only person in the NFL
history dough played in the Super Bowl
and played in the Final Four I was JJ
what that was Jay James said that damn
I'm I've been talking to too many sacks
a lot of sex okay I have some super bowl
storylines for you that I think are
amazing Josh McDaniels told reporters
that at Gillette Stadium they have a
float tank that allows coaches to get 5
hours of sleep in 40 minutes
so apparently Belichick is grinding
these guys so hard because he goes just
sleep in this tank for 40 minutes which
but what would Bill Belichick - right I
totally get it do you believe I don't
believe that well I don't I don't like
why don't we all have floats oh yeah I
believe in the floating I don't believe
in those numbers like you're not gonna
tell me 40 minutes equates to 5 hours
like that's crazy maybe 40 minutes could
equate to an hour and a half or maybe
two hours yeah but it's still another
example of something we always say I
look at Josh McDaniels on the game and
he's like hmmmm tank was not working
this is just what Bill Belichick does
this is what Belichick this is why New
England is New England they're on
another level and they're all and this
is why Belichick unlike a lot of coaches
you guys have heard me complain about at
times right whether it's like Mike
McCarthy where I said he'd never evolved
it was always the 1988 sorry it's all
right relax
1988 like West Coast offense and it was
like ah I don't know I never was taught
that Belichick is always looking for the
new even though he's this old curmudgeon
that we thinks like old school he's much
more of a player's coach he's always
looking for something cutting edge to
that even when they added on to the side
of their stadium in New England like
they made a indoor walkthrough area
because he wanted the walkers to be
quicker and more concise and let's fit
in more to where they had digital boards
when you haven't walked through usually
like the scout team offense the scout
team coach that gonna hold it up and be
like here's to play and you know
everybody's like oh okay you know I'm
Antonio Brown I'm Ben Roethlisberger and
the defense is getting ready to play
Pittsburgh right they have digital
boards on both sides that just pop up so
not everybody has to huddle up and get
around the coach and look at a piece of
paper or
no card it just comes up and they see it
and now now he can run over now he's I
got more plays than onion you know walk
there now I'm here all day it's just no
way go there may that credit goes to
Bella check going this is what we need
to do and how much credit goes to Robert
Kraft the owner going I'm going to give
my coach that because I think I'm sure a
lot of coaches go we need this and the
owners go oh I just paid my defensive
end forty million dollars no I that's a
good point by you oh yeah contact well
no it's brute mr. Kraft is one of the
best owners in football for a reason
he's he's he trusts bill and he's not
afraid to spend money right because the
owner usually would probably be an ego
thing don't tell me how to run my org
exactly right and hey he's had 18 years
of playoff checks coming in mr. Kraft
and he's seen that he's gone well I
might have paid 40 million for that DN
but damn 18 years at playoff checks
gosh I'm still in the positive by about
four hundred million so yeah we could do
a bill yeah you know that's really and
you know like the playoffs you know why
owners like the playoffs right well the
owners kill it in the playoffs that's a
huge thing for them you don't have to
write out a million dollar check to
Aaron Rodgers in the playoff rate a
matter every day thousands L everybody
gets the same amount of money so for the
tickets being sold the cars parking in
the parking lot all the concessions
everybody makes it a lot of amounts so
like NFL players you know guy like Aaron
Rodgers or Brady they're not nearly
making it's it's just you get a flat
checked I think the first round of the
wild-card it's like a $20,000 check if
you go to the divisional round as a
$30,000 check AFC championship it's
40,000 and Super Bowl I believe like the
winner gets 80 now well and the the
loser gets like 60 so it's like yeah
things so it's nothing yeah you're not
cutting out of them checks to your star
players yeah it's a lot but it's nothing
20,000 this show right Wow a drop the
bucket all right so are you guys ready
for our final BET segment of the year
what's our tally left go I got it Sims
all right so last week we each bet 800
dollars on the Rams we both cash those
tickets
I am thanks 800 on the Patriots plus
three left go beat it bet 800 on the
Chiefs minus three which flipped the
lead after I had taken it back
meaning heading into the Super Bowl Sims
is winning with 37 70 in the bank and I
have 33 40 so I'm down four hundred and
thirty dollars which means I am praying
that I've picked the opposite of Sims
just have a chance so we are each
betting 1600 and if you screwed me here
I'm very upset so I let go and I have
done a few segments together and we've
had to kind of talk about the games
already and I don't let go he's a
trickster if an did this don't say your
bet yet because we have to break down
the game oh I had you know I just say I
had to play my cards right so here's the
deal New England is favored by two and a
half um I already know what you're doing
how many years in a row of I beat you
give me the eageriy three I think it's
four I have beaten him in this four
years in a row four years in a row a guy
that has no experience is that fantasy
football flag football paper football
against the guy that played in the
league in his dad are you done
shut up loser Sims I'm gonna give my
breakdown first because I don't know
what you're doing I'm legitimately
worried I look at this game and I see
that everyone keeps telling me this week
that the Rams are the more talented team
everything in my brain goes why would
you bet against Tom Brady in the Super
Bowl and I'm telling you right now that
if I was betting in real life I would
probably take the Patriots but because I
want to beat him and I feel like he
likes to be right I am going with the
Rams just to give myself a chance I need
I need to take the opposite because I
believe that in Sims his mind he wants
to play the betting game but I know he
wants to be right
more than anything he doesn't like
cheating he hates steroid users I'm
mixing it up hoping that you will follow
your North Star and your former employee
Bill Belichick
so I'm putting $1,600 on the Rams plus
two and a half and what and what's the
score gonna go with the score I'm gonna
go with in this fictional scenario and
I'm hoping happen if that happens I
think the Rams are gonna have to start
off with an early lead I think it's
gonna have to be an up and back because
I don't I think the Rams are gonna have
trouble with the Patriots offense
I think the Rams will win this game 31
to 28 is in this scenario I don't see
this is what's yeah I I can't believe
he's doing this this is this is such a
lie why he's gone I'm CNN and pick the
Patriots on a 24 yes but this is not CNN
this is SNL and there's no journalism
that exists here
so screw journalism I'm picking the RAM
all right well you're with me over here
and I'm hashtag facts okay I don't
change history no chance you don't know
where I'm going yet okay sorry shut up
okay you know I'm putting $1,600 on the
Pats let's just get that out are you I'm
picking the Pats what are you crazy yes
I am I'm picking the Patriots and that
means that the fifth year comes down to
the Super Bowl who wins the gambling
championship but give your actual break
I will sure I mean I'm going I'm going
Patriots 27:23 I'm not gonna make it a
long spiel because some of you guys have
heard everything I have to say and I
really can't talk about this game
anymore I feel like I've gone through
like every matchup the world had been
talking about this game for 11 days
straight now but I again I think the big
a hard life I think the big thing that
bothers me is is is the lack of depth on
the Rams football team that's my number
one issue I just know if you go Patriots
offense first Rams defense I worry about
that the pace that we talked about I've
told you guys about the size speed team
right the Patriots are a size team the
Rams are a speed team the Patriots are
one of those team
when you going on the field you just
don't you're not your go damn damn I
just didn't realize Gronk was that big
on film when I was watching all week and
Trent Brown and everybody else okay I
worry about that I worry about hay the
balance of that Patriots offense verse
that Rams defense that's not very big
they get the run game going now they've
got small linebackers they're trying to
help out fill up some hole we're
predicting a blowout I'm not yet I
didn't get to one side of the ball I'm
just saying the things I worry about but
but I worry about that okay
Ben the other thing I'd worry about with
the Rams that the Rams are they're
talented just like our big our big man
Melvin just said it's four first
rounders on the front and all they've
been told all week this is what scares
me
oh it's four crazy em efforts all
they're being tell all weakest or two
weeks you can't win unless you get to
Tom Brady and that's like what Michael
Strahan was told and Justin Tuck was
told right and Prather Ram was tall
right and go ahead to the con Doc's know
this is the kind of rules that you got
to worry about I say freaks respectively
but you got to do that right hey that's
the way so that scares me but what also
scares me for the Rams
you guys saw alvin kamara catching all
those balls last week right Dan I mean
you guys heard of James White before
right what the Rams are gonna have to
switch some things up against the
Patriots and I'm just not sure you heard
balichek make that comment during the
week it's Wade Phillips thirty years of
the same defense that's impressive
but I don't know if that's impressive
verse Bill Belichick when he knows like
he's like oh yeah this formation Wade's
gonna call this this this defense so
we're gonna tear it apart if I don't go
to the other side real quick
of course the Rams are very talented
they can run the football I don't know
if there's that one glaring thing that
the Patriots are gonna sit there and go
we're gonna double woods you were gonna
double Kooks I don't think there's that
thing on the Rams the Rams are very well
rounded and because of that that does
help out got golf and McVeigh and things
like that but it also could be a
detriment to a degree too because now
you don't know what's gonna happen when
the Patriots played the Atlanta Falcons
we knew who they were gonna double right
he's sitting right there look at him
number 11
they were we knew they were gonna double
Julio so a guy like Kyle Shanahan could
go all right I know they're gonna double
him I could play some things off them
right now McVeigh's going huh I don't
know what exactly he curveball he's
gonna throw at me those corners on the
outside are special I think Gilmore can
give cooks a really tough time
JC Jackson's very good the Patriots do
have size
I do think McVeigh is gonna have some
tricks up his sleeve just to change
things up he's a smart guy he is gonna
compete with Belichick in preparation
all week and he will have some different
things to throw Matt knew in good
certainly I'm just so had I think it's
still gonna be the catch in the
Superbowl I did not want to root for the
Patriots nothing against the Patriots
they've celebrated enough but there is
part of me and this is my selfish nature
there is part of me that likes that the
Eagles and the Giants are the only two
teams that have beaten the Patriots in
the Super Bowl right there's something
weird about Diana fees yeah like there's
something weird about that yeah that
division pride like I don't know but so
you're mr. Patriot I'm going mr. babe
you look like a like a thumb and you
know revolution New England debate
threads I'm the cool guy that's written
for the Rams
yeah well I know I'm going when I think
it's like one of my first thoughts that
went through my head when I had to think
about the game I mean the very base like
just to get natural raw I was like our
Belichick and Brady gonna lose two Super
Bowls in a row right that was the first
thing right like my man here from New
York's like nope negative Ghost Rider
yeah so I don't I don't I don't either I
know I'm just come on man it's gambling
all right if you win off this crap I'm
gonna be pissed off all right so what
we're gonna do we have some more guests
coming but we have some microphones
Karen Nicole raise your hand if you want
to ask a question we got a few in the
front what did you see me yelling on the
sidewalk today talking to myself this
morning yeah you did you see me I saw
you you were yelling here I know I saw
you you were walking I was yelling
because there was buses parked in the
right-hand turn lane oh if he's talking
about traffic and that was pissing off
the environment I know I saw you today
earlier today you'll see me - Deion
Sanders the birth
boy Ryan time hey my name is Ben and I
had a question for you Chris I know you
worked in the Patriots Building at one
point I was listening to the lub Itard
show and they were talking about an
Ernie Adams guy that's there is there
anything you can say that you may have
learned from him like a cool tip for a
watching video and learning offense and
sure maybe something he offers to that
team you know that's gonna be an
advantage for them because you're
building that's crazy and ya know I know
I mean he took a selfie yeah he's a
self-made millionaire whose exes played
the stock market doesn't even need to do
the job like that's what he is he was my
dad's first quarterback coach when he
got drafted in 1979 and then he got out
of the football just was like I'll play
with the stock market and he was making
millions just doing that the Patriots
I'm pretty sure hate me because I tell
all these stories and they don't like it
like I see their coaches sometimes
they're like hey Chris and they walk the
other way they don't even want to talk
to me we're not looking at you at all no
they were not and then I think they're
afraid to be associated in me because I
think they're like if bill sees me
talking to him I might be in trouble but
Ernie Adams I learned absolutely nothing
from him you know why because he doesn't
talk to anybody he's always on like a
CIA secret mission and you don't know
what the hell he's doing he's the only
guy in the building that his office is
always locked and he like he walks in in
the morning and like unlocks it like
looks around is like and he goes in but
Ernie Adams I used to love going into
he's he's kind of like socially awkward
but a cool guy
and I used to love going in there when
he I knew he was doing a special project
he had a TV screen like right here and
folders everywhere right and I'd walk in
and I'd make hey Ernie how you doing man
he Beck oh hey hey Chris hey hey doing
and it was always just like that like he
was hiding like his special project I
wasn't allowed to see it and that's what
he does he's Bill's right-handed man he
thinks so any idea what any of the
special projects were I have no idea but
they have people they have people doing
special projects everywhere that's like
like I told you with the JJ Watt thing
earlier how I had a co break
all these plays down to make sure JJ was
on one side of the formation because
he's batting so many balls bill was
saying let's get him on one side and
then have the passing concepts on the
other side and that's just next-level
bill if he was like I said if he was on
Wall Street he'd be the wolf of Wall
Street he's the man he's just so smart
it's scary all right raise your hand if
you got a question Nicole or Karen will
help find you we got a few over here
Karen's on her way hi I'm Marcus and you
were talking about earlier about cousins
already and I was wondering do you think
Minnesota regrets the decision not to
keep Keenum or any of the other two I
don't think so I think they regret
hiring John Dee Philippa I think exactly
right let go I think that's where it
kind of goes wrong there you know that
again I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you Kirk Cousins the top-ten quarterback
in football or anything like that but I
hate when people just ragging on all
used to worse and he's not paying the oh
we paid him all this money and he should
be carrying the team you know hey he
played the game of the business in the
NFL he maximized his money and I
understand that he's got to deliver
right I get that but at the same time I
don't care who you are you you need help
right and he went into a place where the
offensive coordinator stunk
I mean stunk there's no other way that's
why they fired him in week 13 right they
had offensive line issues and all of
that just was a problem for him he still
can lead their team to a Super Bowl but
to me that's like that's like going
Matty Rice or Matt Ryan or how come he
couldn't carry the team the Falcons to
the Super Bowl to the playoffs this year
why because they had like 40 injuries
and it's just not that easy
right yes what's up bro what's up man
it's Michael again um so I had a quick
question for you guys so you played on
tint Bay Buccaneers where after they won
the Super Bowl
um I've noticed a lot of those defenses
the Jacksonville's the you know bears
from a couple years ago the techs in
some of those Broncos they don't the
staying power some of the offense is
that maybe the Packers do or the you
know Patriots do is there something to
that why is it that defensive oriented
teams all of a sudden you know fall off
after year
they only have a shorter window than
those longer Seattle right then I'll
then those offensive teams who seem to
have staying power longer and longer oh
wow well this is gonna answer you the
second Oh random again has just arrived
doing man how you doing man I'm good I'm
good you know I've seen you know you
guys this little sign out there man is
really cute and I want to stop by and
say what's up to my guys how you doing
man you the man
Wow that's Jamal Adams Tommy's the best
safety of football the best safety of
football right now okay hey hey my man
you good I thought he was gonna ask a
question on the planet the legend like
seriously no you didn't interrupt you're
welcome anytime
damn cool kid how cool you are with
those pants on those sweater - huh you
can't hide money Wow can't hide money
that's awesome he is the man oh I feel
good all right can I take a stab at that
one
yes go ahead I think that I've got
what's incredible to me is do you ever
hear someone say we need to hire that
young defensive mastermind I never hear
that I hear let's hire the young
offensive mastermind but all the best
defensive coordinators the NFL are old
like they're all these older coaches and
I think sometimes and this is another
guest defensive players kind of hit
themselves out a little bit sure I also
think that athleticism in the NFL the
X's and O's are more important than the
jimmies and the Joe's that's why the
Patriots keep going it's why the
Patriots probably thought I could throw
the fall 50 yards and the Rams didn't
because they're going oh a medium
athlete white guy he'll figure out a way
to get it done because they have good
coaching and they thought that I could
get it too but I just think that I don't
know I want to hear your take but that's
kind of wrong no I I don't think that
you're not totally wrong with that take
I mean there's definitely some truth
there I think the first thing is why the
offense and stay on the power the rules
right now are made for the offenses so
you can manage the game better on the
offensive side of the ball think about
some of the team's you talked about
right the Jags the Broncos
yeah the Texans kind of some crappy
offenses through this yours wasn't that
bad but the Jags okay
the Denver Broncos I gear again I know
it was Peyton Manning we forgot that
Peyton Manning was the worst rated
quarterback in football that year it
wasn't the Peyton Manning we thought so
it's so hard to replicate our 11
defensive guys we're just gonna go out
there and dominate the game every game
and just sacks and interceptions and you
know you need some help a little bit
from the offense at times you can't
always expect it
those were just special runs I think the
teams you're talking about the Seahawks
did a lot of it but and they almost won
back-to-back I know you know we say it
wasn't staying power but it was staying
power they were in the playoffs or what
six years in a row seven years in a row
we're in two Super Bowls we're a foot
away and a dump call away from winning
to two in a row but you know it's just
hard to play that style game the
Seahawks had just enough offense right
because they had Marshawn it wasn't a
complicated system but they're like
we'll run Marshawn and Russell a dance
around and make a play and that'll be
enough offense for our defense to carry
them so I guess that would be my aunt my
big question is why are all the greatest
offenses in NFL history paired with some
of the worst offenses right why is it
the 2000 Ravens offense with that team
well they're having a lot of money for
those guys right so you can only spend
your money in so many places and that's
where New England again is brilliant
nobody there's no area knew only to go
wow they're paying a lot of money to
that unit right everything's evenly
spread my Bucs team all it was Sapp
Simeon rice Derrick Brooks Booker
mcFarland underrated defense
Ronde Barber the greatest show on turf
right they are the number one ranked
defense that year they did example it
remembers that because it was a high
offense but are we going here are we
going here okay we're going Saints fan I
don't think anyone's talked about this
year how much different with the NFL be
if the Saints sign of dominance 2% of
the Rams mm okay Sheldon Rankin's and
Dominic ensue cam Jordan hey I don't
think it will be a whole lot different I
don't your defense was pretty damn good
but who would who would have been in the
Super Bowl right now yeah it might have
gave you enough to get over the edge
there I don't know I mean I don't want
to say that either way but I mean I get
your point and what you've seen here is
like a people weren't happy with Adama
could sue all year everybody was the
guys kind of hasn't had a great year but
games when the time was to turn it on
veteran players they can turn it up a
notch in the playoffs and you become
more focused and you realize
everything's under a microscope and
you're the only game all you know or
there's only one game a day or two games
a day I don't think it would be a big
difference and I think you should be
happy you didn't do that because yeah
when he might not he might but paid
could also bring in renegades and do
that type of stuff and make them all but
you got a really good defensive line you
guys we'll be right back in the mix of
things next year don't break your armor
again get over it okay you'll be good
where are we going right over here oh
man hey guys Russian really really so
but I want to ask you do you think Bill
Belichick really has something to prove
winning when Tom Brady finally retires
do you do I think that he has something
that for like in his mind yes I think it
I think it fuels him I think it does too
yeah because I think Bill's go in no one
no one says Chuck Noll and Terry
Bradshaw they just say Chuck null you
know no no one knows what Vince
Lombardi's quarterback was back then it
was Vince Lombardi and Bart Starr I just
think though like no I know I feel like
every trophies of Lombardy and Bart yeah
but this Patriots era is so Brady
centric that's the thing that's so wild
to me and what's crazy to both of us is
the first eight years of Brady's career
it was the defense that won all those
championships but we it's revisionist
history giving Brady so much credit for
those Super Bowls because he did have
that one drive in the Rams that was
great but the defense with all the guys
they had I think it 100% motivates him I
also think though that he's a lot like
Bill Walsh where he thought that Brady
was coming to an end and he saw Jimmy G
and he went I'm gonna get out two or
three years early to make the switch so
that I'm not you know left there with
nothing right
three years but I think it totally
motivates me I'm with you left go I do i
I mean you know balichek is definitely
the greatest coach of all time I think
he's the greatest coach in any aspect of
any sport all time I don't think it's
really even debatable at this point in a
league where we've tried to make
everything even it's never even they're
always in the final four the final two
the final one whatever it may be you
know and you know when I have these kind
of conversations I always have like some
of my Boston friends you always bust on
me and they're such a hoot or I'm Brady
and it's not about that but at the same
time they went 11 and five with Matt
Cassel they're 14 and six without Tom
Brady he got suspended for deflategate
right they went three and one and one of
those games they won with the third
string quarterback and so Jacoby
Brissette could barely throw at that
point so like again I do think he wants
to show people it's more than that but
we live in this era right now
where everything is about the
quarterback it's everything that's all I
ever hear is quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback and I want to go
yeah quarterback is awesome I know that
I mean I was a quarterback and I'm all
for that but it's still the ultimate
team sport and you've got to have a
support system like we were talking
about with Matty Ryan and all that Matt
Ryan's the man bob dan would you lose
your four best defensive players and you
got a few guys out of line and Demonte
Freeman's knocked out I just there's
just not many people in the history of
the sport that can overcome that and but
to your point I'm saying yes alright
let's get one more I have no idea Oh
Matty I know you stole my thunder
unfortunately so with all the losses
that we did have with a personnel that
went down the chute talked about next
year for the Falcons I mean we have
Maddie we have some good running backs
obviously defense is pretty to come
strong come but yeah talk to me about
what you guys think I would love to hear
your your mindset you're over the moon
about Dirk cutter yes I've been moving
on from Steve Sarkisian was the first
thing because I really look at all the
stories that I read when he first got
there and he tried to keep Kyle
Shanahan's offense
what great coaches run another coaches
offense when they start off that means
that you're kind of nervous you don't
know what's going on I hope to vantes
healthy because the concussions are
scaring me a little bit I had the
Falcons win in the South this year I
had the Saints get in the wild-card and
then you had the opposite of the
opposite right he had the Falcons making
the playoffs too right but I think the
core of your defense is what's so
exciting because it's speed I will say
this you need Grady Jarrett to come back
because I think he's so underrated in
terms of defensive lineman the lead and
Keon O'Neal and Deion Jones and all
those guys are so it they can do that
because of Grady I will also say that I
think your corners are a little
overrated I think that true fond and
Alford I think because they got big
contracts that they look at it's good
and the ratings are good but they've
been playing this cover three press bell
and I haven't seen either of them make a
play on the ball for a few years so I
think that you have speed I like Dan
Quinn a lot I don't think there's
anything about him that like takes it
off I just want him being more involved
in the defense and maybe mixing it up
and you love dirt cutter I love dirt
cutter to left go what he's saying with
Dan anyway lose Tevin Coleman like
that's gonna suck too cuz Tevin is is
special man yeah
you guys aren't going anywhere no you're
gonna be you know the dirt cutter thing
I do like it's gonna be a step up I'm
not gonna say it's gonna be Kyle
Shanahan but it's gonna be really good
right I do I think his scheme fits what
you guys are capable of doing Dan Quinn
taking over the defense this I left goes
heard me rant about this for a number of
years this is some reason a defensive
coach thing where I got the head job
because I was an offensive coordinator
and now I'm gonna become the head coach
and stop being the defensive coordinator
they do it all the time
everybody go wait you got this freaking
job because of what you do on defense
but you're gonna pass it off like Shawn
McVeigh didn't get there because he was
off it's Courtney go well I call great
plays but here you go left go you call
it no he was I would have called some
great plays so so to that point I think
with your team healthy you are gonna be
back the one thing you guys need a
little bit it's just depth like you saw
this year you know again three or four
injuries just changed your team yeah and
I think you have the opportunity to do
that this year
get Grady signed and then you can build
some backups we
yeah the issue I think with your guys
depth right now is you guys have some
good drafts but I never see the Falcons
play the lower tier free agency market I
never see them pick up specialty MERS I
never see them pick up extra linebackers
every year they go into the season they
go this is who we got and when I look at
the Patriots that paint the teams that
are top in the league at free agent
movements are always the teams that are
up there because they're going our third
string linebackers may be not that good
even though we drafted in the fourth
round maybe we should get another one
the Falcons don't do that and I think
that dimitrov has to try to try that out
a little bit we're about to have a
really good friend Trent Taylor join us
can I get a round of applause please for
Trent Taylor the San Francisco 49ers so
I'm gonna be honest with you guys i DM
Trent a few weeks ago and I said man
you're gonna be in Super Bowl and he
said no I'm not I said listen man well
well really you know if you want to come
out man we'll bring you out you're my
boy and he goes now I'm not gonna make
it and he lied to me lied he says to me
and I had no idea you were coming and I
hear you were very proud of your lie oh
yeah very very proud you know once you
bring the family into it that kind of
makes it ya knows I've been asked like
you feel bad for me like oh yeah man
just spend time with your family go do
that yeah hey this dude has no clue are
you okay are you good
am I good yeah you good yeah cuz we
whooped that ass in Django last night
what bad ass this it's really one to one
though so like we need another match
what is your last game this is the Super
Bowl you lost damn whoo how was the year
just overall the year was rough it was a
rough one for me yeah don't do it I kind
of had I had back surgery like right
before the season started so jump right
into the season like once I get healthy
and just like it was just going slow all
year for me it was a rough to see and
I'm just considering last year me and
George had the same amount of receptions
so
we were like battling like talking trash
all year who's gonna get the most next
season yeah and I think he beat me by a
little bit just a little though yeah he
beat me by a little bit all right so you
are you're really good friends with
George Kittel you saw it last night what
is it like to see your boy break the
all-time tight end receiving yards
record that's kind of feel good though I
was jealous as hell where you're I'm
just kidding that was really cool though
just like to see the way that he
completely blew up all season like he
would have a couple good games and then
like as the season went on it would just
get better and better for him like it
was pretty impressive to see and like
with his yards after the catch he broke
that record to like it was unreal like
you take a little dump pass and take it
for 60 yards like bro you're tied in
you're not supposed to be doing that
because unbelievable yeah it was unreal
it was cool to see do do you think Kyle
was specifically trawling up plays to
create that like we saw the the Georges
fall down and keep running south oh it
was awesome I was dumb yeah yeah that
Rams game for sure like that's all
that's all like everybody was thinking
about because I once it gots like the
fourth quarter it's like all right
Shannon already screwed George on one
record this year happen twice right I
mean you see this guy here right I know
like that like these dudes right here
and I know they don't look like you're
not like well he he looks like normal
Joe like he's not the biggest guy in the
world right and I'm not even trying to
be funny but these guys when you get
them in an athletic sport or anything
wes welker Julian Edelman what I call
white boy Supremes right right you guys
know that from the podcast right
they are so freakin quick it is
unbelievable
like that's what's amazing so I want to
go back to your back injury cuz I know
what it's like with like trying to
restart yourself yeah we're like what
kind of surgery explain it and then like
explain how you felt as you were trying
to come back it was added like a pinched
nerve in my low back so they had to go
in there and just kind of clean it up a
little bit it wasn't like like when you
say back surgery it sounds like a huge
deal but like it it's not you I mean it
is yeah
sure but it sounds like you're on a
table and yeah it wasn't like that it
was just like a little cut they just
like shaved it down a little bit so to
unpinch the nerve but uh like coming
back from that like you were saying like
that's my game is like my quickness like
how quick my feet are and everything so
like trying to build myself back from
that it was like it was not easy it was
a lot harder than I thought it was gonna
be I've never had like a huge like
injury like that before so like I just
thought I was gonna go back on the field
and be right back to normal but um it
was a it was a lot longer process than I
wanted it to be yeah and I mean it was
just a rough season but you know as a
season went on I just like kept kept
going at it kept working harder and
harder and that's why I'm really looking
forward to this offseason right now
because how hard are you gonna go oh
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be real
I'm I'm sick of being here right now
it's time to get back to work honestly
you're gonna be I'm gonna be out in San
Jose
stay out there keep the grind and go and
I was fascinated and we we both look
like idiots
when Nick Mullens first game we were
like oh sit what was your line about
Nick Mullens I said well I was like I'm
not gonna learn his name until he like
plays plays a little bit or something
like that yeah he went out there and
bawled out and I'm gonna dress
what was it like with the team and
everything the team went absolutely nuts
after that first game that he that he
got the win for us he's a just from
Alabama so he was like one of the last
guys who walked into the locker room we
got Sweet Home Alabama playing on the
speakers and he comes in and everybody's
just like it was like the sickest thing
ever like it was sick but like he
deserves it although he's like one of
the most humble dudes you'll ever meet
and just whenever you see somebody like
that has success like everybody like
cheers him on and like everybody wants
that for him and everybody's like so
happy to see that because it was
deflating when Jimmy went down yeah you
know I mean like even the Niner even the
Chiefs came when it happened you guys
were still putting up points on the
Chiefs like yeah still like an up and
back battle how is he doing is he doing
okay
uh yeah I heard he's doing great right
now he's out in
California training at the facility so
hopefully we can get some work in when I
get back but yeah I heard he's doing
good he's out throwing the ball with jet
so those are the two guys right there we
need them yeah
two two two ball players right there how
much [ __ ] did you guys give him for the
porn star date oh it was non-stop all
season yelling what were you guys like
what do you say to someone that does
that
like little jokes here and there like we
had like a team party and everybody's
like okay like bring your wives like
it's a sick like just for us like the
outsiders Jimmy make sure you don't
bring the pornstar here just like little
shots like that it was non-stop where
you guys did you see it because that
story blew up man Oh completely blew up
so were you and George like bro what is
going on right now like I could I was
just like dying laughing when I saw it
honestly and like whenever you mentioned
it the Jimmy use is like the coolest
dude ever here yeah it's not really the
coolest dude ever yeah he's awesome
Jimmy G Q Jimmy G Q like yeah that
defines damn how about your coach you
know I know you know I know coach Kyle
Shannon
Tyler Shannon is the greatest coach
we've ever seen no that's not how it
goes
Kyle our favorite coach me Anna [ __ ] the
housetop the tequilas with him he's done
he got it to kill on all night the Aaron
Rodgers right that's a Roger greatest
quarterback we've ever seen right how's
our favorite coach Neil yes thank you he
got it right all right but no with him
you know of course he was a next
receiver so he kind of sees a game
through your lens X receiver he was
Ebert no that's great I'm glad you're
saying that about it you probably be cut
tomorrow but okay either way though
don't like it is interesting because
it's rare that you know and McVeigh was
this way too but they see the game
through the wide receivers lens really
what does he do what does he talk to you
guys about what kind of videos does he
show you guys are you trying to hence
its know I always knows he likes to
break out videos yourself sometimes says
he broke he hasn't
I haven't seen them no but I think he
knows we'd all laugh at him we'd all
laugh out of them alright but go on him
with the rest of the the rest of the
questions just about him talking to
receivers and how he talked about the
offense or just like your impressions of
him as an OC and a play designer uh yeah
it's it's actually pretty impressive to
watch um like whenever he starts talking
to the receivers breaking down film with
us he'll just like pull up film from old
clips from the 90s and right from like
way back when of like of them running
the same routes for 20 years and there's
like he'll show us like a million
different ways to run the route just
like depending on what kind of what kind
of guy you are like a fast guy like a
big body guy like he shows all the
examples and just like shows us all
these different ways to run it and he
just kind of like lets us create it just
like within ourselves like how like we
just kind of look at the blueprint of it
and then just take it take it from there
yeah is is Kyle Shanahan does he play a
little wave in the locker room at all
when whenever he came out with that new
album this year when Lil Wayne came out
with the album that's all we listened to
at practice for the next couple weeks
and do you look over and he's mouthing
it like his he really into it I honestly
didn't see him I don't know but he was I
mean I'm sure he was that's that's all
you ever hear about have you ever had a
coach like him before
in terms of what I just feel like there
is this new generation of coaches
entering the NFL the Sean McVeigh is the
college and hands like all these young
guys and I hear people like us go they
must be able to relate to the players so
well is that true like does it make it
easier the fact that he's closer to your
guys age yeah I like that a lot honestly
and I think I think most of the guys on
the team do as well
because I mean just whenever you want to
whenever you talk to your head coach
like you want to be able to like be
level with them and you know not feel
like he's like way above everybody and
judging you yeah I think that's the kind
of guy that Kyle is he's just like the
most down-to-earth guy that you can that
you'll ever meet and I think that's real
good for a team because um he's just
like straight up with everybody no
matter what situation it is
and I think that's just really good for
a team to know that you have a coach
that will be straight up with you about
anything and just building that trust
with him and everybody on the team I
think that's a big deal
all right sure left go left go Thank You
Jeff go kicked it with us last night I
did I did tequila sodas I've cold work
and he had to get up early to know he
didn't know he did it
thank strength yeah he's like he's on
vacation until 3:30 every day it's great
I don't think I got out of bed until
1:00 damn you guys really went at it huh
Wow Ludacris that's when you have the
ability to stay in bed till 1:00 like
yeah I know I hear you I hear you all
right so I know you're a student in the
game and all that like you've been it I
know it's only been two years in the NFL
I always like to ask everybody this just
like who's the best receiver you've seen
in person where you're just like holy
crap he's amazing and then the same
thing for Corner
I don't even know yeah I know you didn't
maybe even play against everybody but
whether it was film or just seeing them
um from the sidelines whatever it may be
the first name that comes to my mind is
uh Pierre Pierre Garcon you're such a
kiss like that I thought the guy on my
team that's in your office that dude I
remember just all last year watching him
make plays and practice in the games and
like I remember just like me
Kendrick born Vick we were like we were
just all rookies out there like this
dude is like for real like don't ever
cross him well he will beat your butt I
feel that yeah like he's a scary dude
that's right
we had the the joint practice with the
Broncos and he he went in on some people
really yeah yeah you don't want to mess
with P no I know I know I've heard about
that all right so wait get a picket 49
or DB to tell me is the best corner to
know all DB suck oh yeah you're so
that's another lesson from Pierre Garcon
that's another nice everybody saw it was
the Niners biggest rival what do you
hate more the Rams the Seahawks because
the cardinal it's a hard one I know
the Cardinals aren't in that
nah no there's no beef really with the
car no I mean there's beef with
everybody in your division but I think I
really don't want the Rams to win on
some day yeah really yeah all right I
don't rather I'm not win yeah because
they're gonna have to hear about it
they're in your city it's just gonna be
constant yeah I guess I could kind of
see future Patriots wide receiver Trent
Taylor you know I mean you fit their
mold I mean I'm all in your white yeah
perfect Tom Brady knows how to use those
oh you're at a great offense where you
are cuz your guy you got knows how to
use that slot receiver too yeah Jimmy G
he's like I believe I'm in like one of
the best fit situations possible right
now because like whenever you're worried
about like having a quarterback or
anything like that like not having trust
not being able to build trust with a
quarterback I think that's a big deal
and I think Jimmy G is really good with
that like he he's a dude that's always
working hard like always talking to the
receivers always communicating and
that's the kind of guy you want on your
team so this man Louisiana Tech comes
out dicing it up owning the slot I'm
sorry about your back but I I know that
you're gonna come back next season and
absolutely blow the doors off Trent
Taylor can we get a round of applause I
know it too
I still can't believe that Pierre garçon
I mean he played against the chiefs of
the Giants this year he's gonna go with
New Yorker son
hold it Tyree kill correct next judgment
what so the guy we have is an absolute
legend he's one of the greatest pass
rushers of all time not only that what
he has done for Humanity makes me look
more and more like a degenerate every
day and I get a round of applause for JJ
Watt play home
thank you JJ Watt he is brought to us
from our good friends at Gatorade who
have blessed us today man uh if I curse
do I have to give you an ear muffs
that's alright handle that that's
alright look at you not curse ever I
don't know where you heard that ever
okay good
cuz I just never heard it come out of
your mouth even like NFL Films I don't
think I've heard it come out oh it is
come on well you're a lot to say it's a
[ __ ] this is good [ __ ] because JJ I have
fallen victim to this other people F to
where we say oh it's he's corny all that
I have said it I'm saying it to your
face cuz I'm a man I apologize but I
also want to say did say we could kick
his ass you're a bad [ __ ]
yeah and I'm saying that one was really
bad policy you get back this year after
what you battled 16 sacks most four
fumbles you've ever had how good did it
feel to be back out again
I felt really good Oh obviously it felt
incredible it was such a long journey
two years
tons of ups and downs I mean more more
downs than I ever want to have in a
career but I had a ton of great people
to help me I mean I just had so many
great people helped pick me up on my
down days and then just getting back out
there with my teammates getting back out
there in the locker getting back out
there on the field and being able to
prove that the player that I am because
you know you're out of the game for two
years people have a tendency it's Oh
what have you done for me lately right
people forget so it was really nice for
me to be able to go out there and put up
a good season again where were you ever
in fear that you might not be like I you
know the leg injury was bad but then
back like that's something I was like
cool back for JJ Watt I mean that's such
a big spot for you to get down to the
three points did you ever fear you
weren't gonna be the same guy again uh I
don't know about fear but I definitely
thought about yeah I mean I definitely
had those thoughts I mean you're laying
there on the couch and you can't walk
you can't move you have a big brace on
your leg right your back injuries and
you go through every thought you go
through okay I'm gonna come back from
this and people are gonna say how the
hell you come back from that or you're
gonna see you say I'm gonna be done and
people are gonna remember me for a back
injury and a leg injury right but you
work through that early on you go
through all
emotions you work through them you kind
of get them out of your system and then
there comes a point where you say okay
let's do this let it go yeah just let me
do this right work it through it I'm
gonna be positive and you know it really
is crazy and staying positive and
staying optimistic literally can change
everything because you could you could
go down the rabbit hole
yeah negative thoughts and it's over I
mean right so just my girlfriend was a
huge huge help with that happy birthday
to her she had just come off an ACL when
I broke my leg
oh wow she was actually in the back half
of her rehab and she was still rehabbing
herself and having to help me make food
because I couldn't walk I was on
crutches and so her positivity and her
helping to instill that confidence back
at me was huge you come back season
starts off Owen to win-win-win-win-win
with Sean and the offense clicking when
will fuller was healthy you Jadeveon
that defense how was this season because
that wild ride in the middle there was
pretty awesome it was awesome I mean the
Owen three start obviously hurt I mean
it's not how anybody anticipates it
going but when we look around that
locker and we know the type of guys we
had and we knew we were much better than
Owen three so we just said we have to
win one we have to find a way and I mean
the first one we won was pretty
unconventional in itself I mean it's
overtime against the Colts and fourth
and four they went for it all the weird
stuff but then we found a way you know
we just needed that little taste and
then you just go oh I have another
everyone talks about DeAndre who's a
baller but how he didn't have a
quarterback all those years and he still
put up those numbers for all those years
your defense was carrying along the way
is it everyone talks about the relief
for offensive players it had to be a
relief for you guys to see DeSean be
what he is yeah I mean you go through
obviously so many quarterbacks and
however many years and it is nice to
come into a season no one who QB one is
no one who is the guy no one you having
a whole offseason he's studying the
plays with the coaches he's working with
the offense you're not coming in saying
we don't even know the guys gonna be
yeah so just to have that stability and
to have a guy who you know
go out there and be successful it's huge
all right I mean you're a frickin nature
you're going to the Hall of Fame I'm
just saying that there it's happening
it's going just give them the jacket
already let's go you're truly one first
of all this does it like what position
are you do you think you're a D end or a
D tackle what are you really like I'm a
combination URI I would call myself at
the end yeah but I am definitely a
combination and I like I like certain
spots on certain things like when we're
in a base personnel package I like being
down furthering because there you can do
some stuff in the running game and when
you're in passing situations I like
getting out on the edge but now in
today's game I mean teams are yeah
everything you try to find matchups
because they're gonna put two or three
guys on you no matter where you go do
you know when I worked in New England I
had to do extra work free because of you
I was like quality control in the office
I up in a closet studying but I had to
do it but they were this is how good JJ
Watt was that they literally they were
afraid of you batting balls down so they
were gonna make the formation so JJ
wouldn't be in the same area Tom was
going to throw it and I had a breakdown
formation so just this long JJ Watt tape
oh but that's how awesome you are I hope
you know that I'm pretty freaking ace
you are you had to watch so much of me I
don't like watching my that much myself
no I can only imagine it was kind of fun
but as a frickin nature you are how
about the other guy
how neon your defense like it's gotta be
one of the first times ever you were on
a defense where like you were like man I
might not be the freakiest guy out here
I'm pretty it's pretty crazy for me good
now that you say that my first year in
the league I have Mario Williams overall
I got yeah I've had guys that just crush
weight-room crush the combine I mean
just absolute freaks right so yeah I
kind of I'm kind of used to not being
the freakiest freak out there so yeah
but it's it's cool I mean it's cool we
have guys all over that defense you know
ty Matthew on the back there right
mouthing Joseph frame Jackson Whitney
Bernard Rick knew Whitney yeah if guys
all over and a lot of fun when you get
to play in a defense like that well you
never know where the next play is gonna
come right are you gonna freaks Julius
Peppers calling it quits today I saw you
had that message absolutely freakin did
you watch him growing up I watched him
of course I mean I watched him I mean he
was crazy I mean everybody loves make a
big deal out the basketball player thing
but I mean that is crazy
yeah
right I saw the stat today he's the only
player ever to be in a Final Four and a
Super Bowl Wow how cool is that that a
guy and to do it for 17 years I mean
it's unbelievable what he's able to do
and I think the way that he did it in
the type of pro that he was I have so
much respect for him it's so cool to be
able to honor legend as he walks away
what sure what was your welcome to the
NFL moment looking back my very first
training I mean my very first training
camp I want to like impress everybody I
mean so the very first day of practice
in Houston I'm from Wisconsin
so like 85 degrees you freak out I know
I went down from the northeast end of
the Texas and I was like what is this
week so yeah first day of practice I'm
out there and I'm sprinting from drill
the drill like it's everybody it's a
cool thing to do sprint from drill the
drill the coaches will think your hard
work yeah all the vets are laughing at
me and I'm like one of these guys
laughing it literally 20 minutes in a
practice gassed on the ground gainer a
towel over my back like wet drenched and
everybody's just laughing at me and I
was like oh so you're supposed to like
pace yourself yeah it's it's pretty
crazy and then I got my first lucky
enough to get my first NFL sack on Drew
Brees so that was my very first you say
anything in the Superdome
no I didn't I'm sorry mister Bri I could
I'll tell you what happened I was so
excited I lacked out I looked over at
the sidelines did some stupid
celebration with my teammates and I was
just so excited do you have a guy you
haven't gotten yet I think about that
early Madison or he's got like the
lipstick is like thank God I called that
guy I don't think I've gotten Tom in the
regular season I got him in the
postseason my first a second year in a
league I don't think I've got him in the
regular season so he's up there on the
list yeah growing up like who was your
who was the guy you like was the legend
to you it was Reggie
yeah okay the Eagles thing I do I think
I knew that's why I was asking for you
man it's great I watched his videos and
it's insane they're really in our oven
moves it's like I bash this guy six
yards I lift this guy off the field
sanity and so like every so like this
season like he'll do something in the PR
staff will come to me and they'll be
like you just did this and you were only
the second player to ever do it and
every time I say don't even you don't
even you say no I know who it is yeah
every single time it's
and when you sit down and you really
look at his stats he was insane yes yes
I think the guy had 21 sacks in a 12
game season he did his most sacks were
against my dad his whole career he's
nobody he sacked more was my father
yeah the deadweight rule I need to find
that guy is is because he smushed my
father to the ground so many times
that's how amazing was Saint he was
incredible I mean he's he's I grew up in
Wisconsin watching him he's a legend I
know many people remember him as an
Eagles player and I can only see him in
a Packers I get it because he's the
helmet barely fit his head right on that
Packers try especially if you have a big
face man are down the center of the
Super Bowl game and I was like so my
buddy is Quintin Nelson we had him a few
days ago right what's the scouting
report that you have facing them three
times this year because people are
saying he's one of the best offensive
lime in the league all pros of rookie
what's your view he's a good player he's
a really good player I mean to be able
to come into the league and perform at
that level early on especially on the
offensive line which is obviously a
difficult task a great job with it I
mean he's tough he's physical I smart he
knows how to play the game
and they've done a good job up there
obviously I have to give our credit to
them with the way yeah
playoff game and everything but I mean
they do a good job
and Andrew does a great job behind them
too I mean the thing that Andrew did so
well this year is he got the ball out of
his hands so fast like he knew where he
was going with it he didn't try and make
too much of it he got the ball to the
guys need to get it too quick and that
obviously makes a little easier are you
gonna ask the same special of course
okay cuz you just teed it up that was
perfect perfect yeah that's why I do
what I do you do yeah Emma Street
because of that right like I always like
to ask guys especially like a who's like
the one guy that has just been a pain in
the pain in the ass your career where
I'm just like damn right I gotta go
against this guy this week who is that
if anybody popped your mind
Marshall yonder yeah Marshall Yan does
he was always a great player my rookie
year in the my rookie year the first I
think it was a third game of the year I
played him and I had a horrendous game
I'm telling you I got pulled from the
game three separate times is that right
Dan third time my coach was like I think
we're getting I D like coach said put
his helmet away he's not going back in
and I sat there thinking to myself well
I'm cut I was like I'm done I'm done in
the NFL what was he doin D you got the
it wasn't really he's obviously really
good yeah but I was a three technique
and he was it was a cut-off block a
simple football and I hadn't played
three technique in college that much so
I was still getting used to the NFL it
was cutoff block every time I got cut
off three four three
so they just kept running the play
because obviously like run at the rookie
and [ __ ] right so I got pulled from
that game but then we played them in the
playoffs that year and I had two and a
half sacks against him but eat every
after that every year we seem to play
the Ravens for like four or five years
there and he's such a tough guy and he's
such a competitor they had a guy get
knocked out of tackle he bumped out the
tag on the play tackle he was always a
guy I loved battling yes you're a movie
quote guy which movie do you quote the
most that's tough I do like long as he's
which god bought oh oh me I'm always a
Tommy Boy he's always tight that guy in
a little cork oh yeah you could get a
better look at a steak or a t-bone but I
would say I think lately I've been used
a lot of dodgeball quotes really uh
like the ESPN the Ocho oh yeah yeah I
think it's a bold strategy cotton yeah
dip dive dodge duck and I stepbrothers
is a huge one wedding crashers right
have you ever met Will Ferrell one time
really fast I think I backstage at the
ESPYs or something really would make you
nervous if you met them that's a great
question Thanks yeah just phenomenal I
think Denzel Washington really gonna be
really cool yeah I mean I'm a huge
obviously Remember the Titans growing up
and everything else he's ever done uh so
I think he'd be really cool yeah I met
Samuel L and it like blew my head off
because I just saw the Pulp Fiction yeah
say what again and I was like oh man all
right so you are here again because of
Gatorade Super Bowl 53 what are you
doing with them what's going on we are
talking about G zero which is zero sugar
so it has all the electrolytes that
Gatorade has zero the sugar so for a guy
like me that's perfect for offseason
workouts it's perfect for resting up on
the couch after workout because there's
none of the sugar so but it still has
all the electrolytes to help you refuel
and they have a deal right now if you go
to Gatorade calm you can get 20% off by
the promo code Gatorade SB saucier -
right SB yes and and your food vise is
what my nutritionist just is trying to
start me on this new no gluten no dairy
oh I grew up in Wisconsin Yeah right you
were pretty a milking cow I wanted to go
to your house but I I don't want to go
down that road I'll just I'm moving I'm
going to New York next week right Pizza
is everywhere yeah it's pizza you gotta
break them down I'm gonna I told them I
said we'll start this after New York
Yeah right
if we started no dairy come on so let me
just say you're a 48 long I have no idea
what that means a suit sighs I just want
to make sure the jackets hey brothers
got a hug thank you guys see mmm what an
amazing week here in Dan Tana's in
Atlanta I want to thank all of you guys
for coming out you guys have been
amazing I feel like we made dreams come
true JJ Watt what an awesome time our
buddies George kettle Trent Taylor teo
chad johnson Derwin james melvin ingram
stop Michael Vick - Sean Jackson there's
more and I can't remember all of them so
I need you to kind of Kareem Jackson
annex and then there was another one on
Tuesday Jarvis Landry holy crap I forget
Tudor and James my is what the host does
you're supposed to know these names oh
yeah Quinn Quinn else oh my god Lee so
honestly that was all great but to see
all of you guys I'm gonna get [ __ ]
he loved you so much
Oh little Lexi don't worry but it's a
good cause crying lemon homie crying
left go me just like Jordan you and
Michael Jordan joy all right all right
would you stop it over here all right
here we go first of all for the year
seriously it's been a great podcast year
we really appreciate all of you all
right
always a special shout out to my man out
of left go research all right rod Simba
for what you've done for the opening
music talent watch out for him and Kevin
minor right here you see this random
white guy in the middle here yes you
wouldn't guess this but this guy's flow
and rap is he that you love his rap
should check out the video of the rap
that he made for Simza left go he lives
in Austin Texas but just another example
of awesome fanbase guys that really
appreciate you
you always know open book DMS send them
to us there's no question that time out
are we answering teams no you want a
yeah but yes we will never a giant way
from them blast blast you the man at us
we did it Wow
yeah you're going Patriots I'm going
Patriots are right okay I cry at Field
of Dreams it's all good I cried during
Mike Ryan Armageddon okay when they get
off the spaceship and he goes permission
to shake the hand of the daughter know
the flavors man I've ever met I'm always
like a oh oh oh so don't worry but it's
alright don't know me josh josh vendrick
who really makes this whole thing work
damn damn damn he's in the back right
now [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
good-evening foursomes peace out homies
i can't even look at him LEF koe
that's what we needed he's gonna make me
cry now holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]